[Music]
time now for some pft on yahoo sports
peter king mike florio here with some of
the biggest stories in the nfl and over
the course of the past week the covet 19
situation has become the biggest story
in the nfl so much has happened peter in
one week and one of the big things that
occurred the patriots had a positive
result for of all people their franchise
quarterback cam newton taking two planes
to and from kansas city one with 20 or
so who had close contact with cam newton
and the other plane with everyone else
acknowledging that they're not out of
the woods yet the incubation period
continues to be the doughnut hole that
the nfl will never escape
and whether it's the patriots or anyone
else this cascading effect that we saw
last week for the titans could still
happen with new england patriots and it
continues to hover over whether or not
the nfl is going to get all 256 games in
this season
yeah mike on sunday i had a prominent
epidemiologist tell me
that
you know
to be safe
you should not engage in anything like a
football game
uh for four or five days after
uh
you know the the positive person
basically has come out so i talked to
the nfl talked to alan sills about that
the chief medical officer
and his
point was basically well
the person who was infected
was not infected on friday
you know he first showed
uh positivity on friday
but
in the nfl's opinion and mike also
in the nflpa's
opinion because they do this together
that
what has to happen is that
you test positive on friday
but it was tuesday or wednesday where
you were exposed to it so if all the
people on your team have been exposed to
you for a couple of days
then what happens is that is the
incubation period i think they were
relatively safe
in playing this game on monday night but
you're absolutely right there still
could be a positive test or two
left over because the incubation period
is at it is at best shows up four to
five days afterwards and that is the
donut hole in all this you said it no
matter how many tests the nfl gives its
players look at what happened with the
tennessee titans
positive tests for six days
after the first positive showed up that
is what the nfl is going to battle all
season
and peter the nfl's approach is
to assume that there will be people who
test positive who get into the building
but to do everything they can to limit
the chance of it spreading once they're
in
i think the better approach would be
put everyone in a hotel the patriots
have that hotel right next to the
stadium they're making it available to
players there aren't many players who
are staying there put everybody in the
hotel then you minimize the chance of
anyone becoming positive because i just
think it's inevitable if a guy gets in
who's positive someone else some way
somehow is going to get it we saw it in
tennessee we're going to see it
somewhere else and until they put all
teams in hotels that that reality is
going to hover over the entire season
and threaten to leave us with fewer than
256 games
i think you're right mike but i also
think that
if you tell 2
460
people you know the nfl players plus
uh you know another
750
coaches and essential staff
hey by the way for the next three months
you can't see your family i do
understand the alternative and the
alternative is
you may lose game checks you may not get
paid i get it
but i think now that only one team has
become the miami marlins which is the
titans uh my feeling is that there's
very little juice right now to send
teams to a hotel
well it worked for the nba in one
location it worked for the nhl in two
locations it would work for the nfl i
believe if they do it i feel like
they're going to wait for the house to
be further on fire than it currently is
but as of last tuesday morning it wasn't
on fire at all when you think about
what's happened over the course of the
last week it shows you how quickly the
virus can take over that's the challenge
for the nfl he's peter king i'm mike
florio we'll see you for more pft on
yahoo videos later in the season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports